[Music]
you're entering an epoch in which humans
are responsible for phenomenon that we
used to attribute to God or nature the
world has moved too far to favor the
individual at the expense of community
do we live in a time what I call the
politics of amnesia in which we are so
focused on all kind of material issues
that we forget that we are also
spiritual being and that the spiritual
being is in need of spiritual food there
is no recipe for happiness obviously
we're probably born with something
called the happiness gene which is a
capacity to be more or less joyous more
or less relaxed the only thing that can
really change that is actually having a
goal if the goal you know involves
others it's this extraordinarily
gratifying thing to see the face of
someone who's surprised because all of a
sudden you're looking at them then all
the things that require happiness like
food on my table warmth in my house a
roof that works I'm very simple in the
needs that I want but I want my family
and friends that's everything
and ideally a big pile of good books
that's what makes me really happy
today we had a conversation about
politics about power how the world
always changing and the conference was
entitled the ring or what will rule the
world is the drive for power hunger
you know depredation so strong that
there is no turning back we're faced
with the world we're existential threats
to mankind demand collective solutions
yet nations of the world are divergent
no one part of the world is the same as
the other but clearly climate is
something that will affect all of us
large-scale migrations as well that will
be climate related but also dislocation
of States I'm trying to argue against
pessimism and fatalism through the
making of beauty through faith and you
know confidence in what humans are
capable of doing at their best there is
always a point of return and there is a
possibility for connection a possibility
for selflessness a possibility for
empathy for me it starts in the
classroom it starts by working out what
skills you need for young people that
means what languages that means watch
what understanding of Technology I'd be
able to anticipate the kind of problems
we face through bioethics through
climate through AI through robotics and
really being prepared for for difficult
questions in the end the technological
singularity that humanity is creating
though is not emerging just from one
isolated research lab it's emerging from
the coordinated activity of people all
over the globe
involved in all different walks of life
and different countries and of different
ages with different perspective to solve
this problem what the different
countries to work together as part of
globalization how to protect our own
humanity and in this respect I thought
it was very interesting that the top
military leader of the United States of
America was telling us look military
power is the wealthy you should prefer
not to use right usual political
instruments invest in community building
invest in education invest in health
care if you know the facts you know the
risks it's a good time to start acting
let's make sure that we realize that be
six exception and lowest rule begin our
nature
so let's if it's not in in be face but
in awareness in a kind of cultural
awareness and then try to give people
instruments in in their hands which will
make it possible for them to deal with
their own fears and what I hope will be
the outcome is a renewed respect for
community and renewed respect for
cultural integrity try simple I saw a
piece on a boring life with no
dislocations no war no famine and to be
considerate I think it's important for
the next generation to work on this
because you want to give your children a
future it's just that simple
these amazing things that are happening
they're happening because of the efforts
of each of us right and anyone can
plunge in and make a substantial
difference
either the creation of some new
technology or the way that new
technology is rolled out and and
deployed in the world at large
each tech company that started using
advanced tech for a beneficial aim I
need to work about that's created
depicting using tech being used in a
positive positive way I mean each of
these things contributes somewhat toward
the same the one of my fears is that
which we all understand the benefits of
science and technology but the danger is
that we are forgetting what else we
needs to live a meaningful life our
lives being like a sea and wave you know
and and you never know which ways the
ripples are going to go and the sea and
the waves are of course you can't
separate them from each other and we're
part of that so we're all connected
constantly and I believe in those
reports so I try to begin as many
ripples as I can
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]